this week as the covet 19 pandemic
continues schools are reopening around
the world from london
to st petersburg to wuhan china where
the whole thing started
but in the u.s it's been a mixed bag as
the continued concern about the spread
of the virus
and rhonda the increasing death toll
the virus does rage on here in the u.s
with over
6 million cases and since march 183
000 deaths the numbers are almost so
large they're
they're almost incomprehensible and
today there's new reports that the
viruses cases are spiking in the midwest
indeed well joining us to talk about
this is dr boris leshniak he is the dean
of the
university of maryland school of public
health and was the acting surgeon
general during a good chunk of the obama
administration
dr lushnik thank you so much for joining
us thanks for having me brian
let me start by asking you big picture
do you see any uh bright uh
light at the end of the tunnel well big
picture uh we're not
exactly where we thought we'd be at this
point in time you know there had been at
least a
hope that we would run into a summer
lull with volvid 19
and that we would be expecting a surge
coming up in the fall and winter
what happened obviously was throughout
the summer time we never got to that low
and we have these sporadic hot spots as
you mentioned currently in the midwest i
think south dakota
and iowa are two states most affected
right now
but it's really been spreading
throughout the united states and so
therefore the pandemic sort of moves on
unabated
last week at the republican convention
president trump promised there'd be a
vaccine by the end of the year
take a look at what he said i want to
ask you about what you think of what he
had to say
the entire planet has been struck by a
new
and powerful invisible enemy
like those brave americans before us we
are meeting this challenge
we are delivering life-saving therapies
and will produce a vaccine before the
end of the year
or maybe even sooner
dr lesnar presidential hype or is there
some truth in that do you think
well there's a lot of progress being
made on the vaccine front let's remember
that prior to december 31 2019
which was why it's an important date
because that was the date that the who
office in china was
informed of an outbreak of people with
pneumonia
due to an unknown cause so we're now
nine months into this
and in those nine months obviously this
has been a novel
virus that's been identified right and i
love using the word novel here because
it
really is both definitions novel is
brand new our immune system is not used
to it
and secondly novel in that it's been a
page turner
throughout this whole process we keep
learning brand new things so
incredible progress in that in these
short nine months
we now have 36 different vaccine
candidates that are
in human clinical trials yet i don't see
it happening
by the end of the year in terms of
having an improved vaccine
ready to go uh there's still a lot of
work to be done ahead of us
again a lot of great progress right now
we have nine such vaccine candidates
in what's called phase three clinical
trial which is now
thousands of people getting the vaccine
it's being
looked at from the perspective of does
it work
phases one and phase two of vaccine
trials really look at safety measures
safety measures are still being
tabulated here but at the same time we
are finally at the point of seeing
whether things work or not
this has become the new space race
globally we know the russians have a
vaccine that they say is ready to go we
know the chinese are are continuing on
their vaccine front
and many other nations are involved but
i don't see it happening by the election
and i don't see it happening
by the end of the year perhaps early in
2021
will we be at a point where perhaps a
vaccine will be
proven to work but at the same time then
we have to get into
mass production of that vaccine and mass
distribution
dr lajnack a question for you from
rhonda schwartz rhonda
it's the beginning of september the
classic back to school week
in some countries some cities schools
are reopening
but new york city due to the virus has
pushed back the delayed the reopening of
schools
what do you say about this what's your
take on this
well ronda again it's very difficult to
say let's just
open up the schools while we still have
community spread of the virus going on
right one of the main features of spread
of this virus is dealing with the
density
right of how many people do we have
close together
and i know a lot of the schools are
reopening and have taken into public
health recommendations right the whole
idea of physical
distancing the mask where the hand
washing that continues to be
very very important and yet i'm
concerned about this idea of
lots of people gathering together this
becomes risky not only for potentially
the students themselves
that is spread between students but
certainly to the adults who are teaching
in those
classes and then the potential of
bringing it back home so this
has to be done very wisely and very
carefully it can't just be a cart launch
that we're opening the schools and we're
ready to go
doctor final question for you do you see
too much of the heavy hand of politics
and the decisions being made about this
absolutely you know the problem from the
get-go uh regarding the national
response
uh uh in fighting covet 19
and fighting this is disastrous
pandemic has been that it's been hyped
politically all along like when did it
become sort of politics right to say
whether you're mask wearing or not
i think the major mistake has been that
the health communication
the public health communication began
coming from political leadership
as opposed to coming from public
health leadership uh and you know
politicians need to be involved they are
elected leaders of our society to be
able to move us ahead
but the reality is communication needs
to be coming from the scientific base
side from the medical base side from the
public health
side and therefore i think it's become
very confusing for the american public
depending on who's saying what and who
they believe in
that shouldn't have happened
indeed dr boris lushniak from the
university of maryland school of public
health
thank you so much for being here tonight
great thank you so much